hello and welcome to a very special
episode of top 5 scary mods of the week
I'm cam this is 7 7 is this this is
Kevin it's Kevin the real woman he's on
the show we're in America right America
right yeah yes we all right ok good
welcome Kevin welcome we've we be
morning to make this episode happen for
so long
so what's the snow this this game is
Skyrim and oh right right right oh I
remember what I'm gonna say it's about
goddamn time
yes yeah what I had to say about that
yeah the fans have been asking for it
we've been reading pleading for flights
just to come and do this we have to make
to this think'll III whatever he's about
and nobody points about that all they
care about is is the van Nord on the
episode and Cameron's gonna be joining
us for the entire show yeah so let's get
some odd number one right now
okay sent on Kevin our first mode of
today is customizable camera so Sepp
tell me a little bit about this so I get
working when we when we're running
around at first person and that's all
great we've done some immersive
first-person mods and they are great too
but sometimes you want to run around in
third burst always so uh as you want to
look at your bug while you're wrong
exactly or Bobby oh yeah yeah yeah but
I'll be wrong angle of the book is there
possibly a wrong angle of Gavin's oh
yeah there are other right angle sexy to
the buff okay several writer than others
I mean really
okay so so Kevin what would be your
perfect angle at your buck because we
make it happen it happen I would say you
know I would say if you can go like a
nice 40 degrees I like and like from
from from the ground okay no so we
didn't really get an upshot yeah I mean
if you the cheek yes cheek and maybe if
you can get some like potatoes okay you
asked for a Lobos here we can be
endeavour to get the potatoes when it
says all this numbers me I'll explain
the numbers alright so the camera top
left is the main one so you get a
horizontal adjustment and the bicycle so
we're going over so we're gonna be
getting a real good one on the right
cheek okay oh the N a purely left K
let's guess I'm good right you so you
want your right cheek okay and then you
want to drop it down right eye drop it
like it's hot okay
Jase oh hey there's yeah L on the cheek
that's pretty good I think you could
probably get even lower just hammer it
read to me crashing ah [__] pressure to
the floor okay okay there we go
whoa Wow Ann Annis do but alright thank
you are there was something gorgeous
from the back there we go yeah yeah
that's that's how everyone's wanted to
play Skyrim so far yeah you also have a
second one
when you get in come back so so we're
summer fighting it - oh it's like your
life yeah oh okay oh yeah you've got
you're having a weird out-of-body
experience I'm not quite sure what you
donated this right the problem with this
is that I've nowhere to be seen
all right I think I broke it I think
you'll zoom is way too extreme problem
was this it I think the problem is
probably everything so this way you've
got you've got a bird's-eye view of the
battlefield much more convenient for for
killing in the NIT I want to
over-the-shoulder okay let's see if this
works
yeah Wow okay get a kill move
just-in-time yeah perfect all right in
the junk manager always goes for the
junk okay it's give me a tough one to
follow but Kevin what is mod number two
called this is divine punishment for
mention of errors in the knee which i
think is so overdue about down time all
right
you look like paper copper he would
mention arrows and knees that's not good
it on it talk to him again
hurry up watch this guy's haha come on
I used yes then I took an arrow into me
yeah that was marvelous oh thank god
I didn't even care as we killed him
that's just a natural death yeah he got
what he deserves its own interventionist
I was so good you know there's actually
a follow-up to this mod by the same more
creator if you're interested which means
that the same thing happens when they
insinuate that you are upset because
somebody stole your sweet roll let's buy
some more guards they already don't yeah
kill the Drago you couldn't possibly
know
shut up looking to do some hunt now the
boys need supplies construction magics
Jesus my gosh I used to be an adventurer
in a lot and I took an arrow and then
that's what you get JA I think this
might be the most perfect rod you've
ever showcase I think we just keep this
one on all the time and I forget about
it man time everyone again I'll just hit
cuz sometimes you just say that to you
as you walk past there may be like nope
okay guys time for mode number three
which this week is pure evil armor set
and I said this is pretty evil
yeah the skulls is this evil nephew
Kevin I know you like to be evil I add
I'm actually I am known for my innocence
a really honest which is so it's Kevin
Van Nord your antithesis is that Helio
canary because Kevin van nought of
course evil to the core yeah he's pretty
much my my evil twin okay as it were be
still oh yeah very much here you feel
his pain I do feel it see if he was
capable of physical pain you would also
feel and he absorbs my anger yeah which
he can now deal out with this gigantic
sword although those skulls are
definitely gonna get in the way so the
thing I'm not say about this or truck
maybe assist me is the placement of
those skulls versus the sword shaft
makes that sword extremely phallic oh
wow no it's not just you okay that is
quite a phallic blade I'm getting um
there's there's some fun like thing
about my I don't know like I think I
probably think about penises more than
you guys I don't know if I didn't mean
it's improper
it's just me it's just me that's pretty
good cuz he's pretty good-looking in the
skirt too yeah it's kind of got kilt
vibe going on which you know I respect
the most evil do is always work if a
breeziness
yeah - yeah - ketta you gotta you gotta
keep suing that's cool yeah you're in a
sword good shape yeah the evil engine
needs a breeze otherwise it uh you know
overheats well uncle we're being
entirely not evil enough in this armor
so that's good maybe so go do some evil
get a moving fitting this guy Oh shop oh
good Evil's pretty evil great work on
the evil lair thanks thanks
this sort of knock his head into the
water get in get in there right
why that's a great view oh I go oh I'm
busy stop shooting arrows at me I'm
gonna fit the head in the water happying
all right sir I got plans and work it
off okay no even close cleared the skies
the skies oh no I think we're more evil
Neetu in kiss okay killing that guy
altogether not that evil okay who's a
bit of a joke oh yeah yeah there we go
no swords uh in fact the whole set is
extremely pretty legal no definitely not
you know I've ever had oh it's have you
seen the kind of shoulder pads he's
going on here I see it's like a lot
about a rhinoceros
oh oh oh really bad about myself no
commercial words oh thank god the better
a human it makes you yeah he's he's the
antithesis yeah he's the other Kevin
these guys are just like Philly
nonchalantly oh my god gonna happen here
perfect it's all okay
I'm sure nothing are you gonna save me I
should bash your face it that's the
wrong thing to say pal oh I'm gonna kill
your wife apparently that's pretty harsh
all right guys time for Maude number
four which this week is axes of hatred
said what's going on
so basically you'll probably remember
from two episodes ago we asked you if
you would make us the battle ax of
hatred from oblivion and not only did
you do it you did it four times
Wow so Kevin whoa what we're gonna need
you to do is pretty HitFix you're gonna
need to judge which of these battle axes
of hatred contain the my hatred so ever
thing this one just stole his soul uh I
think you look very out for oh yeah
we're yeah oh god I need to see all the
stumbling into that decapitation both
just add to get to have their heads
ripping well it does it steal Souls Hey
and life so I'm pretty hateful now this
is a energy and there's heaven van
Norden excitation alright alright number
one I just I mean can it be can you be
more hate to know I don't know yeah
that's this is very very good
yeah there we go that that made very
short work of those forsworn let's go an
arrow in the face yeah yeah look at the
head look at that head go Wow
I said axe number two this is uh this is
from Hybris the gray oh and this is the
battle axe appeal to remove heads pretty
well fairly fake oh yeah yeah that's
good yeah I'm liking this one so far it
doesn't look like it steals all these
souls are intact oh yeah more or less
yes less evil than what happening okay
okay look nice though so this is take a
moment let's take a moment to just yeah
it's not bad it's not bad yeah like it's
a bigger ax so it ya can maybe take more
heads at one time let's try this one
Oh sab this one also removes heads and
it's got that it's got a really nice
double bleeding finger like you double
blade yeah yeah okay we can use it from
any side football really fans this is
the only one that's fully fully made
from scratch and actually there's a
there's a hidden extra on this one I'm
probably haven't noticed yet [__]
oh yeah take Ted's takes heads and names
but you'll notice cam if you were if you
were to zoom in on that as a as an item
yeah that is me quite clearly a chicken
wearing look wearing the crown of the
king of Skyrim yeah yeah Wow Kevlar sir
to set up the hatefulness there oh my
god I don't know how am I gonna choose
you need to show me my stuff no oh my
gosh we've got one more to go
final one battle axe Oh another together
double blade that there's more tasteful
traditional so glowing green this is
gonna do something to stamina I'm
guessing so this one is just the battle
axe of hatred looks like more of a
bludgeoning - oh and it's a more far
though it's got fire as well I need any
more cannon fodder hello friends oh yeah
yeah so this one this one looks like
it's got quite a few spells
yes but is it the same animation every
time oh it should be a different one
that dependencies are really fond of
that one yeah yeah likes he likes me
right heads look what can we say I would
have thought with all this same
animation that they'd know don't get hit
oh yeah bend over all right when he
swings the end I'll duck no you miss
chickens are the epitome of evil oh yeah
um have you you've heard of it like the
chicken some dude like didn't quite cut
its head off right now no ever months
with no stub the sarin that happened
yeah yeah so chicken I mean yes it's the
chickens let's go me this way it's gotta
be there like speeches so that's the
battle ax of hatred by dummy toss
dumbest as you're a few oh I just
realized when you equip it listen very
carefully
you guys is it chicken noise oh yeah
turns a winner perfect yeah
all right the time has come for the
final mod guys and this one is called
the chicken returns and here he is this
is our user voted mod you can tell it's
look at him go Lucky's returning potato
sack on the back yeah well he's got
Quicken dings yeah Frank yeah he's been
there full of supplies where is he going
safe so he's going wherever he chooses
cuz this guy doesn't play by anyone's
rules and literally I zone out by
talking to him carry one dwarven arrow
added so basically you just talking to
this guy
the chicken is no longer confident in
your abilities and has also saved your
came in case you get old
what oh really I did the chicken is
grated you one wish
I want to see some more nice please oh
yeah oh yeah see somewhere nice Wow
where is he gonna send us this chickens
incredible Oh this much you know what
just this it's nice if you know with us
is quite luck there is over there he's
there jump over and see him yeah this is
somewhere nice thank you thank you
chicken when I was the old pack point
gold weapon cc7
weapon weapon again shovel okay such a
[__] yeah Oh activates ghost form once
the chicken does not appear at check-in
haha that's it he knows how I look best
oh he's obviously I use auto saved us
yeah buff as well that's that's nice
chicken is a chem van Lord that's what
we like to hear
Oh knows what's up it finally he knew
how wrong that was the chicken finds
this amazing Oh
why we nothing to even clean to me we
don't get it takes your wife
thank you for marking yourself very good
where's he off to did he singing the
clouds begin to go gray what's he done
to the weather did he do this the skies
go gray did you hear him yeah like
garlic you know chicken makes these guys
know great how did he do that oh that's
weird
chickens have I told you they were the
epitome of evil yeah look what it's John
we should have believed you're back in
to get him
toggle come over pack this is combat oh
yeah we've got to do something now all
right chicken get involved you better
help out I eat pretty pacify charging
he's hidden charging he's definitely
interested oh well Kevin's just near the
veg mother neither veg
wow what a team is to make chicken get
it boss is someone we saw amazing sounds
up for the burials oh that's what God
made oh he can finish your Balkan I'm
always trying to you know oh it's just
some in the Jumeirah yeah I forget when
your weapon embalming tool wow they're
completely chicken is immoral Lord
amazing wait it's uh it that is his ring
yeah there we go
Hazen alright alright two more large we
have chicken - chicken in a while Kevin
do you want to do the honors sure okay
this is all on you punch that chicken oh
man inverted camp
yes yeah that's weird I know punch that
you get yes
and we are out rag dolling naked into
the sky oh man just like I was like it's
just across right there
that is awesome I mean I go see gates to
this wedding day that's the shot oh we
got me and the very good at we got the
whole deal whole package oh legitimately
the whole package a steak yeah that was
awesome that was awesome like I I was
gonna say I could have done it better
myself but he did yeah but that J hat
yeah okay so Kevin an order of you being
here we've got questions from our lovely
viewers and they're all kind of about
you so I mean they usually are we're
gonna throw them straight at you you do
so first one said go for it
so Callum Simmons know who would win in
a fight odd or nor the eternal question
or door nor I don't have a chicken so I
have to go with Kevin van Norden chem
panel if you heard of here
yeah better video but is it one of those
paradox things like if one destroys the
other the first is left removal objects
well I mean if we eventually I think
it's sort of like that Harry Potter
Voldemort thing like one cannot live
while the other survive I'm just
imagining then Arnie predator like you
know high-five arm-wrestle that's what
I'm imagining it would become like that
type of fight the never end a awesome
next one Gareth Bryn says who does he I
assume that means Kevin van dort like
Morecambe or you is that you so which of
which of us to basically she's he before
us this is it yeah this is why we put
you in the other heaviness but it's that
it's gonna become awkward here yeah yes
good oh nice question yes
cam that was easy oh no no no I can't
father a chance between the man I love
but he just did alright next question
comes from Alex are at B 986 and he says
at me and said have you ever attempt to
start a van Norden mean like he's so
tough he can beat up the chickens and
Zelda without blowing them up or you can
beat the Dragons and Dark Souls with
just a pointy stick
what do you think about a van Norden me
Kevin well it depends on whether the
pointy stick is a euphemism or not
alright I'll go over that a game isn't
that I'm okay with showing up Van Horn
well yeah I think that beginner day me
Ben Lord he did of course marry himself
yeah I never saw the episode on
Valentine's Day yeah he married himself
I mean there's no one else wrong there
was no one else good enough he's
searched it's Adam and Eve not Kevin and
Kevin yeah yeah he was the ultimate
narcissist yeah yeah so Paul M wants to
know what's it like having a legend
named in honor of you brackets him what
is that so when it says him you mean
Kevin vanore yes yeah so I'm I'm very if
I were Kevin van Ord I would be very
pleased with it named after a legend
exactly yeah yeah I think that's the
right way that is the right way now
there I I really want to make sure we
were looking at it from a writing erect
very careful my angles today so that's
good and then cam who said the last one
what enemy character and Skyrim because
you both in those problems and why
they're all right Oh a serious question
it's like a real mess you know you're
gonna aim it that we're gonna do it you
get in here yeah okay well alright so
Lydia I love you
but thoughts you are a goddamn idiot
yeah she's and I'm afraid that there
just comes a time when as much as you
love somebody you need to have respect
you need to have sneezin come in there
need to be able to spend time together
yeah uni I mean she's just yammering on
it on about the dragon boats look girl I
need the room filled with the bone this
it you cannot take that that is my man
cave that is also a euphemism yeah and
you know the birds in the man had a good
white run but in the end it's it's my
room that was good that was nice
Wow all right final question all
Swannack so the name Kevin van Lord I
must say like them that the riff on your
name that was actually the idea of
Martin Gaston mmm he came up with it he
was like you should call your guy Kevin
van Lord but how what was your first
reaction Kevin when I emailed you saying
do you mind if we name our schedule a
day yo yo name stupid kids yeah yeah
that's where that ought give me a damn
pretty reactions yeah that's that's
that's pretty much it yeah much no
actually to be fair you were very kind
you actually emailed me saying we
decided to kind of do this thing um oh
yeah I did honor your day I even do
after the fact what's happened what am I
gonna say at this point we kind of
strung up yeah making Americans look
even more uh we've ever be egotistical
do they already do by kept saying I
don't know I don't think I want my
attention of the project yeah so we did
kind of force the subject sure just ruin
the magic altogether you go and I say
guessing you want people you phrase your
question like that the last thing is
it's tweeted at us saying have I found
Kevin's home street and sent us this
picture oh wow oh wow
van Nord Avenue yeah uh that's except
where is this I don't know I have no
idea where it is
seeing it's interesting because okay so
a little story on my last name so my
last name actually means from from the
village so fine Ford's is actually what
my last name comes from so this would
actually be more towards from the north
yeah
so there's actually a little bit of a
difference between that
up go for it what if we go for the end
of the show we've got three mods for you
guys to vote on yeah that we will of
course showcase the winner next week so
the mods are White River cottage said
boss this one all so it was just a
beautiful looking home uh right by River
would our favorite place yeah it was
very quaint and I thought it might be
appropriate to vote on okay so that's
your first choice second choice is the
Joker follower you want to take a look
at this don't you yeah I do
and it's here's a legitimate Joker
follower he is kind of very serious he's
a little too serious to me
so you keep it for that but or a WoW or
a Iram stargate mod if you are into
stargate like i ashamed Liane I used to
be yeah it's about time then you can
have your very own Stargate now that is
in a sky education you didn't know
whether actually return got that bag
it's pretty what is it that you like
most about Stargate is that the
fantastic acting or is it the Egyptian
gods um I think it's mostly the
fantastic acting and it's the spears
that fire magic Oh them choruses oh and
ER and the worm creatures and then while
rampages yeah there are really great
yeah I think it's mostly the great
acting though ten seasons of great mmm
anyway if you want to vote on any of
those especially the Stargate mod yep
you can do so by going to tiny well I'm
not I'm not strong arming anything else
now but if you wanted to vote for the
Stargate mod you could do so a tiny real
calm forward slash ready semi blog where
one put the boat leaking yes what'll be
really disappointing if they vote for
the White River card it it's like oh how
nice Gary you're the one it's up to them
what the way we'll just throw the
Stargate motivated next week we've just
drilled favorite how is out of our
control man we've given power to the
people the people to sit they may decide
don't be boring yeah make the right call
oh but that's it the important thing is
of course there will be no scary monster
next week I won't be what we only doing
Kevin where we gonna be uh I figure was
it
hey night yeah a night early on a date
where three three-way date night so no
time to record the same time also the
XIII is that
893 cabinets people as you're having you
in the show it's been simply wanted you
for so long so thank you so much yeah
sobbing along yeah yeah I was it the
skill of once as fine that's fine with
me games on how do you this be over five
five yeah maybe the Alliance system will
be a five six alright five seven chicken
heads out of ten yeah yeah
okay there we go stop back I can live
with mediocrity ever you said like your
mediocrity is my bread and butter
yeah yeah a bronze medal still a medal
yeah alright cool guys thanks so much
for watching will of course be back at
any time so we will see that